8 news now is sponsored by our community
pride partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
findlay automotive one of our community
pride partners is asking in the
community to step up with them to help
out our town and joining me now is tyler
carter from the finley automotive group
the sponsors of this segment to tell us
more about the second annual step
challenge welcome tyler it's good to see
you great to see you mercedes thank you
so this is the second time that you are
doing this tell us a little bit about it
yeah so uh so we've been supporting our
american heart association through their
heart walk for a long time for like 11
years i think this is our 11th
consecutive year i chaired their walk a
couple times back in 11 and 2012
and so every year we were sponsoring
heart walk well last year they couldn't
do it in person
and so we came up with something
different to help support them but the
reason we support the heart association
is because
heart disease is the number one killer
of americans you hear about covid and
cancer and all stuff heart disease and
we all know someone i know i've known a
lot of people have had heart attacks or
strokes and so we want to help out and
improve treatments and and and make it
better for that so that's why we support
the american heart association you guys
are all about helping the community tell
us a little bit about this and how
people can step up to help yeah so
here's what we're doing so the last year
they couldn't have the the walk in
person so we formed had each of our
dealerships form a walk team and so we
ended up with 15 teams
20 people of a team
so that was 300 people and we walked
over 29 million steps over a 10 day
period
personally i walked in it got
competitive the last three days i walked
over 15 miles a day trying to win the
walk challenge so no did you say 15
miles yes yeah it got a little out of
hand so
but anyway so we had each of our stores
put in some money and we ended up
raising twenty four thousand dollars for
the american heart association and uh so
it's a it's it's a is a fun thing it all
it covers one of the things one of the
reasons that heart disease is a problem
is people get a good exercise and so
we're encouraging our people to get out
and walk a little bit and also raise
money for a great cause so this year
again still got a pandemic people with
heart disease are uh more susceptible to
covid so the heart association didn't
want to do the walk in person again this
year so they're doing a walk where you
are and so we're just encouraging people
to do something similar to what we did
form a walk team do a step challenge
with you know your family group your
church group your your company whatever
and raise some money to help support and
try to prevent heart disease which kills
so many people that we that we know and
love and you'll be doing something good
for yourself at the same time i don't
know if you can beat tyler's 15
15 miles a day yeah well only for three
days
around in circles pretty much yeah
that's incredible step up and take your
steps to help the american heart
association just like our friends at
findlay automotive group for more
information on what they do at the
american heart association you can call
and get more information 702 789
or visit heart